لا نعرف أي تفاصيل عن
وفاة هذا الأمريكي في السودان ولكن ما
نعرفه هو أن وزارة الخارجية
كانت على اتصال بأسرته،
ويأتي ذلك حيث
توفي مئات المواطنين السودانيين
نتيجة لذلك.  هذا اندلاع
القتال الأخير، الآن وزارة الخارجية
والبنتاغون، إنهم جميعًا يراقبون
الوضع عن كثب بشكل لا يصدق، فهم
يضعون الموارد في مكانها الصحيح
لتنفيذ عملية إجلاء محتملة
للدبلوماسيين الأمريكيين الموجودين في البلد الذي
لم يتخذوا بعد قرارًا به.  افعل ذلك
في هذه المرحلة، وبالطبع فإن أحد
العوامل الصعبة هنا هو حقيقة
أن هناك هذا العنف المستمر على
الأرض، لذا يراقب مسؤولو وزارة الخارجية
عن كثب لمعرفة ما إذا كان
وقف إطلاق النار الذي تم الاتفاق عليه يمكن
تنفيذه بالفعل على الأرض حتى الآن.
لم يكن هذا هو الحال في الواقع ونحن
نعلم أن وزارة الخارجية
لا تخطط أيضًا في هذا الوقت
لإجلاء المواطنين الأمريكيين أو في
البلاد هناك حوالي 16000
أمريكي متواجدين هناك بالطبع العديد
من هؤلاء أمريكيون سودانيون مشتركون
المواطنين وسمعنا من
نائب المتحدث باسم وزارة الخارجية في وقت سابق
اليوم أن هؤلاء الأمريكيين لا ينبغي أن
يتوقعوا أي إجلاء أمريكي منسق
في هذا الوقت، لذلك نحن مستمرون في
مراقبة تلك المساحة التي قالوا إن
وزارة الخارجية كانت على اتصال مع
مئات الأمريكيين الموجودين في  السودان
كايلي أتوود سي إن إن وزارة الخارجية